you know what I would hate the most if I
ever became a vampire not eating Garlic
as the legend goes vampires hate garlic
and it can be used to protect yourself
against an attack from Dracula but why
garlic garlic has a rich reputation and
pungent smell ancient Egyptians believed
this gave garlic incredible healing
powers when the Herb's popularity grew
across the Eurasian continent garlic
became associated with protection from
Supernatural evils the practice of using
garlic to ward off vampires specifically
was popularized in 1897 by Brahm stoker
in his Infamous novel Dracula since then
Garlic's power over vampires is now a
familiar part of the legend in the 1970s
a Romanian Church handed out garlic to
parishioners those that refused to eat
it were accused of being vampires man
that was an awkward day at church but I
still remember it like it was yesterday